[Music]
hey everyone welcome to culture binge
this is the wisecrack podcast where we
explore the ins and outs and ups and
downs of the cultural zeitgeist
i'm michael joined as always by the guy
who recently promised me you could turn
1 000
into 10 000 if i just trust him alec
and the woman who once sold me on her
french countryside airbnb
which was actually a terrifying cave
that i had to be rescued from
serbi uh how are you all doing today
well how are you
good you sound low not emotionally just
can't hear you that well
but i'm sure we'll we'll fix that in in
just a gif
um so we got a lot to talk about today
um
we got beef with the government not in
the way you might think
we're going to learn about new ways of
scamming money and
um i guess some french people got stuck
in a cave i i i'm
in the dark on this one so i'm excited
to learn about it but to get started
let's do some slaps and chaps serbia i
would love to start with you if that's
okay this week
yes how's my volume it's better now i
can
i can hear i just want to make sure that
you are the loudest person and then alec
is a little bit less loud
yeah excellent uh so what chaps
is the situation going on in india it's
so heartbreaking and distressing and
i'm so sad and i hope things improve
quickly
uh what slaps i recently learned about
this app called be my eyes it's also a
website be my eyes.com
um and so it's a website that brings
sight
to blind and low vision people and
uh be my eyes.com connects blind i'm
just going to read this from the website
because it's really well written
be my eyes.com is a free app that
connects blind and low vision people
with sighted volunteers
for visual assistance through a live
video call
so this is how it works a blind or low
vision person
will request help through the app and
then
a sighted volunteer will receive a video
call and the person might need help with
reading instructions or maybe they want
to check
the date on like milk to make sure it
hasn't expired
or maybe they want to distinguish colors
read directions
or navigate new surroundings and
someone i know recently received their
first call
and the person who asked for assistance
wanted help doing online research that
would have taken just a really long time
to do on their own
and it's a great app i love that it
makes a positive impact on someone's
life
and whether you're a blind or low vision
person
or you want to be a sighted volunteer
download
be my eyes app for ios and android today
i just can't help but think about what
if a low vision person wanted to do
something illegal but they needed help
to do it
and i wonder which volunteers would help
them do that all right that's awesome it
depends what the crowd yeah so if you're
a person who would use that app maybe do
something like
um call someone and be like which one is
the methamphetamine and which one is the
rock candy i need to know i was thinking
like shoplifting from home i can't hear
alec opperman at all
i think he's muted himself sorry i
didn't meet myself i was thinking
uh like helping someone shoplift from
whole foods that's that's
that's what i want to do don't you do
that does one of you
no you're thinking you're thinking of a
guest we had
maybe oh okay oh yeah
um no stealing from whole foods is great
although i realize if you go
when it's not at the rush and you're at
the self-checkout
there's more likely to be employees just
standing there so i think if you are
going to do that which you shouldn't but
if you are
going it's more crowded because the
employees aren't there but also if i'm
working at whole foods
getting paid you know 12 an hour i don't
care steal anything in front of me
i don't work there though so that that
doesn't matter i
just don't think i would want to get in
trouble for shoplifting at whole foods
just don't that's why you need you need
the good guide the volunteer
on the be my eyes not that you're a
visionary
and you're just on the thing and you're
like i want to steal this
tell me if i'm at the right okay um do
you have any ch oh and you did your
chaps as well i forgot we talked about
situation in india
horrible and i think we're all thinking
about that and wishing we could do
something to help but sadly none of us
have
uh access to large reserves of vaccines
or the community
donate money oh yeah you can't donate
money i guess i just mean that like we
can donate money and that feels good and
i'm sure it can do something
but it's like we can't do like the real
thing we need to do you know what i mean
well we could we could you know
write mean things about bill gates and
how he
has created he's used it as billions of
dollars to advocate for patent
restrictions that make it impossible
for places like india to get waivers to
you know i don't like it
let's make another video about how bill
gates sucks uh i didn't know this
oh yeah yeah lindsay maguire no such
thing as a pretty gift there's a lot of
um
good journalism about this specifically
with the oxford astrazeneca vaccine uh
oxford university
wanted to make the the intellectual
property free and open to the world
because they
you know had received i think government
support um
and you know bill gates and his crowd
came in like no no you need to patent
this um
and so not that specifically oxford uh
that the astrazeneca vaccine would
be the the the sort of magic ball in
india but it's like this sort of patent
regime of laws around it
um google about it there there is good
journalist tim schwab i think is one who
talk a lot about this
yeah what a monster yeah yeah everyone
google it and get real mad
um speaking of real mad but first real
positive
alex laps and chaps oh yeah uh still
boycotting chaps everything's great
oh here's my chap uh serbie on her slaps
always has something like wholesome and
uplifting and positive for the community
and i think that's great but what chaps
is it makes me feel like the garbage
human that i am
yeah um so i reflect back what you said
what chaps is serbia reflecting my inner
rottenness um
but what slaps is uh i discovered a new
podcast i don't even remember how i feel
like
several people told me about it so sorry
if i um
am ignoring them or not giving them the
credit but maintenance phase
uh i went i did some hiking listen to
like four episodes it's about the diet
and wellness industry
um and how most of it's [ __ ] but
like in a way that i find it is very
uh like refreshing smart and nuanced uh
these are
journalists who talk a lot about like
methodology of studies
um you know they are not overwhelmingly
they did a whole episode about halo top
uh which i thought was incredible
because it's like listen it's a tasty
food
uh it's good it's not necessarily like
going to kill you
or anything like that however like all
the marketing claims are super [ __ ] up
and so like don't feel bad eating halo
top if you like it but also don't fall
for all their [ __ ]
they did a thing about the biggest loser
which is a very [ __ ] up show i've
learned i never watched it
um one of my good friends was on that
show if we ever want to talk to him
about it i'm sure he'd come on
i do did they sign an nda any and he's
making a documentary
about his experience on it and i bet he
would love to talk about it on here
yes this is normally something i would
say when we're not streaming but i'm
just going to say it that
that we should we should invite him on
he's a really great guy yeah but anyway
maintenance phase i think it's really
good i think the research is good the
reporting is good and uh
people who like calling out [ __ ]
things should would
like it that sounds really good i'm
gonna look that up and i actually am
sometimes people say that you know like
on a podcast because they want to give
this semblance so we're all friends and
take each other's advice i'm actually
going to listen
to that um great um
yeah um so slaps and chaps
hmm i have two slaps written down but
i'm gonna pick one okay
i i got really happy in the past week
because concert started coming back
um i started to get pretty excited
because
i i saw a friend who who works in the
music industry
and i asked him if he had like any news
on when concerts would come back and
like he was like a spy he kind of like
looked both ways and was like
you're gonna start hearing stuff in the
next few weeks and he was right
um a lot of outdoor venues where i live
have started to announce concerts some
indoor places for the fall
live music some of my favorite things
one of the things that makes me feel
like i don't want to just like you know
go into the ocean and never come back so
i'm very excited that that's happening
um the chap which is kind of related is
so i did um and to be clear so no one
judges me i'm fully vaccinated
um but myself and a fully vaccinated
friend my best friend in fact who hadn't
really hung out one-on-one and
done some in a long time went to a
brewery this weekend
and sat outside and had a beer and i and
it was fun but also i found it really
hard
to like readjust to being out in the
world and seeing all these people and
all this stuff and i was
i guess like and this is very naive i
had the realization i was like oh man
this past year might have [ __ ] me up a
little bit
oh yeah and and i just wasn't quite
ready for that so now i've been thinking
about like how i need to plan a gradual
readjustment into socialization
but i'll call that a chat because as an
extrovert i was excited to be back in
the world
and the world was scary yeah
this was hard for you i'm terrified for
people who like
who aren't who are introverts and don't
like being outside with other humans oh
you guys are
[ __ ] just thinking about it's making
me like
my heart's palpitating but in fairness
too i'm an extrovert who's also neurotic
and anxious
so i think let's let's let's play my
stuff on my extra doses of
neuroticism and anxiety um i'm sure for
everyone else it'll be fine and great
probably we're all gonna die okay so um
let's
let's get into our topics like i said
before we're going to talk about some
caves we're going to talk about some
finance stuff so definitely get your
bankers on the function you're going to
make some big investments by the time
this is done
but let's start we're going to get like
real political i know
everyone you listen to this and you
think we often avoid things we're subtle
we're going to get right into it
and we're going to talk about the
government's beef problem
and the government's attack on big beef
i'm just kidding
but fun story this week so the
government or the president released
some new climate standards
that's good you know we care about the
environment blah blah blah that's great
but the media response on the right was
kind of
funny and it was kind of funny because
uh larry kudlow for one
put out a statement or tweeted or not
said something on fox news
about how the president wants us to all
be drinking plant-based
beer and grilling brussels sprouts first
of all
what does he think beer is made of does
he think wait did he really say that
swear to god look it up i thought i
thought you were being
like exaggerating like uh-huh
plant-based beer he would have dumped
but he actually said that
i mean here i'll give i'll give you the
quote um on
yeah this is larry kudlow said this um
that he wants you oh yeah he said on
july 4th you'd have to throw back a
plant-based beer with your grilled
brussels sprouts
said that on fox news uh i'm glad that
people understand what beer is
i just like what is this what what
certain people have they just been
drinking beer thinking they're drinking
like
like the like spinal fluid of a cow
i've been waiting this is like the uh
the labeling creep like
for like gluten-free this will happen
like gluten-free oats like oats are
gluten-free
why are you advertising this but i'm
waiting for the beer to start getting
the plant-based label
yeah bud light is gonna be like the
first plant-based beer
it's healthy it's made from plants guys
yeah it's grains and water if there is
if your beer isn't vegan you have
problems i guess the only i'm trying if
there's any good reason
it wouldn't be vegan there are beers
that are not technically vegetarian or
vegan because there's like
fish bladders used in the process and
most vegetarians i know don't care
enough to look into it
yeah and there's some i know there's
some stouts that will use like a lacto
fermentation so like elements of lactose
uh to make something a milk stout but
whatever this isn't a beer podcast we're
not those guys yeah we're dudes with
beards but for this isn't an ipa podcast
so that was the initial response and
this all started because of a daily mail
article um that falsely stated
that if the current administration's
climate plan went into
into effect we'd only be able to have
burgers once a year now
of course that's that's not what was
said um
what was mentioned uh in the climate
plan had to do
with emission standards um and as i
think
most of us know at this point
the ass gas of cows is a big
source of carbon emissions
and related to this whole thing the
food website and magazine epicurious put
out a statement a couple days ago
about how they were leaving beef behind
so
if the government isn't really leaving
beef behind our next most trusted source
for democratic process
epicurious a conde nast publication
is and i think this was kind of
interesting so i'll just look at really
quick the uh the top of this article you
can find it it's on
on epicurious called the the planet on
the plate why epicurus left meat behind
um but they say this this is the lead of
their article it says for any person or
publication wanting to envision a more
sustainable way to cook cutting out beef
is a worthwhile first step almost 15
of greenhouse gas emissions globally
come from livestock and everything
involved in raising it
61 of those emissions can be traced back
to beef
cows are 20 times less efficient to
raise than beans
and roughly three times less efficient
than poultry or pork
and i think this is something that most
of us know
at this point but beef is is real bad
for the environment and of course
there's
if one is a a vegan for reasons of of
animal welfare and anti-cruelty that's
dope too
um but there's some pretty valid
environmental reasons for wanting to cut
back on or eliminate
meat consumption and this magazine
decided to do their part
by not giving their their their
customers
and their fans beef recipes anymore um i
did not see anything about plant-based
beer
and this this was mandated by law by joe
biden no i'm just kidding
yeah joe biden came in with this climate
gestapo and stomped them all to the
floor
sorry for everyone listening we have
established that joe biden is not
actually trying to legally mandate how
much beef you eat that that
no you know that guy loves beef he's a
meat potatoes guy just look at him
yeah um no well and anyone can look this
up there's there's a
legislation that is being proposed by
the administration to do climate things
uh part of the climate stuff involves
trying to have
less uh carbon emission one of the
things that that leads to greenhouse gas
emission like we just said
is livestock which is 15 of it globally
so
all all the administration proposed is
hey
greenhouse gas maybe we cut back part of
that would be livestock but there is no
thing in any government document that's
like no burgers for the people you can
still have your burgers
but epicurious poses the question should
we maybe
cut back on that individually should we
stop as sort of an ethical
uh for an ethical reason should we stop
publishing recipes for for beef
based things so i'm trying to think out
of my my co-host here i think one of you
is is not a beef person
sir do you consume beef no okay so no so
i'm the only one
i think who's on this that even semi
regularly consumes beef
um so what do the non-beef consumers
think
both about i guess this reaction against
uh uh some policy about reducing
greenhouse gas
and the idea that a food magazine would
take it upon themselves
to stop promoting the consumption of
beef
uh i think it's an interesting idea i
think
any little bit helps and um
i think it could encourage readers to
rethink their consumption
and maybe make adjustments to help the
environment
yeah i think that um
nobody really tries to do this but i
think the the the smart strategy
is not people can't eat hamburgers but
like hey look at this other delicious
food and i think for
years and years we've just been cramming
down people's faces like
unless there's like a piece of chicken
or meat on your plate it is not a meal
and i think
people a lot of boomers think that but i
think people are reevaluating that and
realizing how like awesome and filling
like cauliflower and broccoli and
those grilled brussels sprouts can be
and so i think that's good i also
thought it was interesting that
epicurious
stopped doing it stopped putting recipes
a year and nobody noticed
yeah i should have mentioned that part
yeah yeah um
so so there's that and also i i do find
the whole thing very interesting of like
there's america we beef when really like
getting into
this is a little bit in uh upton
sinclair's the jungle and sort of the
the
the news cycle around that but the beef
trust which were i'll call them the the
facebooks and twitters of
early 1900s meat industry um there were
these huge
you know uh cow and meat monopolies
basically convince the american public
that like they need
meat every single day every single meal
you know they were
they invented modern sort of uh
industrial agriculture
and and made beef much cheaper but it's
like basically this pretty new thing in
the last hundred years that we're
eating the amount of beef that we are
it's not some sort of like
oh i'm you know living like people did
thousands of years ago or even living
like someone did in the the 1700s i
think
um people sort of cling on to this in an
interesting way
yeah i mean i i think it's you know it's
been
the thing folks have talked about for a
while even even leonardo dicaprio talked
about this
in his climate documentary from a few
years ago which i forget the title of
that i watched when i was very tired on
a plane
um it's called douchey mcdouche saves
the planet
um but something came up in that movie
people talked about this for a while is
you know i think there is
a potential benefit from like a mindset
change around beef
um i personally because like i'm going
to fix the planet as a one-man show
have have tried to think of like the
consumption of beef is something that's
like a very special occasion thing
and something that's only to be done
with like good quality beef that's
raised in a responsible way
um but like the epicurus thing to me
is cool like that's a i think it's a
chill thing of them to do
i don't think it's the sort of thing
that can lead to the impact that we need
and i think sadly it does fall under the
umbrella of like
the shift of responsibility to consumers
and then like the abdication of
responsibility for
i mean in a sense like i i i guess you
know
and i don't want to get get political i
stay out of politics but
um you know in a sense if the daily mail
was correct
and the government was actively
restricting factory farming that like
would be what we would need to actively
cut down
on that level of emission so you know
from individual responsibility i think
it's a good thing epicurious is doing
that i guess that's a good precedent
i think it's a a good thing in general
for people to consume more plants and
less meat um
whether or not you're doing it because
you want to be ethical like like moby
who who has vegan for life tattooed on
his neck like a freak
um or you're doing it because you care
about the environment which is dank
um but yeah i it's just one of those
things where like
the epicurus thing cool yeah gonna do
long-term things gonna really change
stuff no not really
but maybe i'm being cynical you know
yeah go with serbia sorry
i just think i think something's better
than nothing and i'm glad to see
a company do something so i do agree
with you that it's not going to make a
huge dent in
how we need it to but maybe it'll start
a conversation which is exactly what
it's doing
it was funny that their post was
sponsored by light life the meat
substitute brand
yeah so it's like yeah you can't even do
that without corporate branding
i i think the you know i'm all about the
i think
corporations have as you said
specifically shifted the
burden of responsibility on consumers
instead like hey don't mind us we're
pumping
you know hundreds of tons of co2 into
the air
but you know you should stop using
plastic straws i do
really agree with that argument but i
feel like meat is a specific thing in
that
uh there's not i mean maybe there's ways
to reduce the co2 emissions of cat but
it but it's not like
it's not like they're a factory that's
using fossil fuels
and it's up to them to you know use
cleaner fuels and scrub the air that
they pump out there
or you know buy carbon offsets i mean i
guess the meat industry could buy carbon
offsets but
that's not perfect either and so it's
really i think the one thing where it's
like actually
this isn't the way that
certain things are mined irresponsibly
or produced irresponsibly like there's
there's no
breaking from the eating of a cow with
like the co2 emissions of a cow if that
makes sense
yeah and i guess too like the whole
thing seems like a
like we can focus on the cow stuff but
even as the statistics show
if we were to cut out you know cow
consumption completely that would be
what sixty percent of 15 so what
eight to nine percent of greenhouse gas
emissions and that's like
what's the other 91 kids and i think
that's
one of the issues that much of the other
large-scale greenhouse gas emission
is is the responsibility of a very small
private
not by small i just mean not a lot of
private companies that do a lot of
damage that we're not talking about
and that our personal ethics can't do
much about
yeah i i this is a little unreal i just
want to say the the comments
happening in the live chat are
interesting because i'm used to
saying something like oh i don't eat
meat and everyone calling me some sort
of soy boy cuck
fine whatever i probably am that uh or
like weird conspiracy theories of not
conspiracy theories you like where do
you get your protein bro like dumb [ __ ]
uh i would say 90 of the messages are
not like that and it seems like
at least the audience today is you know
various degrees of like
industrial farming is the problem or uh
you know me it's like your whiny baby if
you can't eat less meat
uh and so i i find maybe i'm witnessing
a cultural shift maybe it's just
based on who clicked on this video i i
don't know i find it very interesting
i'm used to just
constantly shutting up about my dietary
habits because people
uh uh like to make jokes no people are
accepting you
and your diet for who they are and i
really appreciate that
do people ever alec when you go out to
eat with or when you used to go out to
eat with other people
did others try to force you to eat meat
or like make comments about how like
it makes them uncomfortable that you
don't eat meat
because i've always had that happen to
me no but also i
i i became a vegetarian as an adult and
i feel like the people i was around
were not that although i will say when i
was younger and i've said this before
when i was young i was
a piece of [ __ ] i i would like make fun
of vegetarians and vegans and be like
come on you need a pepperoni man
um i was a bad person so it's fine don't
be that person
yeah i've been vegetarian a few
different times in my life
but i'm just with fairweather but the
first time i went vegetarian was in
college
and when i went home for like
thanksgiving or christmas my mom started
crying
because she didn't know what to cook for
me anymore and like couldn't conceive
of me eating food that wasn't meat
and there was a lot of like but you put
but i can make you chicken right and i
was like
hey mom is that is that based in the can
that thing walk and make noises and
reproduce well we're probably not going
to eat that one
yeah i don't have a face i feel like
we're past that though like who i just
don't know anyone who would like
make fun of a vegan or vegetarian oh
they're they're all over the place
[ __ ] whack
that's stupid like there's so many good
reasons to make fun of your friends
that's a bad one so if anyone is
listening to this and you have a friend
you enjoy making fun of and your main
thing is that
email us and i will i'll come up with
better things you can make fun of them
for
than that because that's just easy
they're they're haircut
uh they're no i'm
you know what you want to do if you want
to make fun of your friend do an
ancestry.com or like 21 and me
for them and find out horrific things
about their ancestors
yeah so you can be like oh so you're
german on one side right went back a few
generations
not looking so good chief um or
something like that i don't know but
making fun of people for that is why
have you have you had a hard time
serving with people being addicted to
you for
not wanting to eat animals i have had
that yeah or like people saying
one of my friends uh husband so he would
say to me it makes me really
uncomfortable that
you don't eat meat and you don't drink a
lot it like makes me feel really bad and
i was like why do my life choices make
you feel bad about yourself maybe you
should
engage in some examination maybe it's
about how like your wholesomeness makes
me feel uncomfortable because i'm a bad
person that's just what's happening on
the
dietary level with this person this
sounds like someone who just like has a
straight up drinking problem and eats
too much meat
and then sees someone who has healthy
relationships and boundaries with those
things and it's like it makes me
uncomfortable that seeing your
boundaries and resolve
reminds me that i have an inability to
do these things because i think the same
thing about people
that don't drink like i hate that yeah
like when people that don't drink get
treated like that's weird or when
they're like it makes me uncomfortable
like
why like that to me that just means you
have a problem if anyone ever says to me
like
it makes me uncomfortable partying
progression on my being
they're too young and leafy
guys there's so many good uh i'm gonna
[ __ ] up the name olaira brassica is the
name of like the plant family that's
brussels sprouts broccoli etc
there's the class of memes about them
it's just
vegetable means who would have thought
so good google yeah
you know good yeah and here's the thing
too everyone a lot of us have been you
know
inside a lot haven't been as active as
normal
we're getting ready we talked about this
last time for like you know a real wild
summer
whether you're vegan or not whether you
care about climate change or not
just like eat some vegetables for a few
months and then you'll feel better
as as you get invited to a a lake
hangout or a backyard
party or something like that you want to
feel healthy and energetic this summer
yeah we're now
we're in the pocket of big plant and i'm
i'm encouraging you to eat some
vegetables
um or and you know what donate some
money and serbia will do a vegetable
mukbang
um yeah i want to make one comment
before the next guy in britain says man
this is silly of course it's okay to
make fun of vegans i just want to say
guy in britain your food sucks that
that's what i have to say oh [ __ ] this
got aggressive
um guy in britain is someone that also
brings for a while there's some there's
some good stuff
the problem i'm sorry all the other
british people yeah
i don't know i just think like let's
make i just it's not a fun way to make
fun of i'm not impressed like i don't
think if i saw someone
rip on someone for being vegan i'm like
wow look at this
intellectual wit it's just like boring
do something better
very lazy yeah very lazy okay
um so let's move on oh we've all figured
this out the government's taking our
beef
away we will rebel we'll talk about that
more in two weeks we have a plan
um another part of american culture
along with beef consumption
is sketchy business alec i feel like
you're on the beat of a sketchy business
news or sketchy investment news this
year
maybe i've uh mentioned this before uh
there's a youtube channel
that's worth checking out called
coffeezilla uh kind of spelled exactly
the way it looks
uh he he covers like financial scams and
you know i like scams
and you know just weird subcultures
well yeah i like scams i like uh uh
yeah i just really grifters man whether
they're anti-vaxx grifters financial
grifters
elizabeth holmes firefest like it just
just i just want to mainline it um
but the uh
oh jesus sorry i'm looking for my notes
but they are
on a different tab i got too many tabs
it's okay you're gonna find them
you know go through your tabs we we can
you know
manage things until then um
okay i got it so coffee's at coffeezilla
did um
an interview uh with this academic the
academic published an article
it's called towards an untrue
entrepreneurial economy the
entrepreneurship industry and the rise
of veblenian entrepreneurs
um the the authors on that are hartman
spicer and
crabby crab but but the whole interview
is kind of the industry of people
who want to teach you to become an
entrepreneur uh this is probably very
familiar to
you know even watching coffees on videos
you'll get ads for like starter drop
shipping business my branded diapers and
make eight thousand dollars a day
um you know that's sort of the most
scammy version there's certainly
sort of uh you know in the financial
space
take my financial hack start a business
etc etc you've got things like trump
university
you go to a hotel you take some sketchy
class i would even say that like
nexium is kind of this you might say
mlms are
a version of this sort of entrepreneur
economy where you are
selling people stuff to want to become
an entrepreneur um
not to mention self-help etc
uh it's it's a very wide industry but
what i thought was really interesting
is basically the thesis of this article
uh and coffee still has like a 50 minute
interview uh
with the guy uh that i recommend people
check out uh
but here here's a here's a quote from
the article the growing entrepreneur
entrepreneurship industry and the way
has transformed entrepreneurship
are an important aspect of understanding
the decline entrepreneur quality
uh basically there's more entrepreneurs
than ever but they're also
success is more rare than ever the you
know percentage of people succeeding no
i'm not talking about like people who
become the next uber but i just like
make a basic sustainable growing
business
that that's down um here's a quote by
levering
leveraging the ideology of
entrepreneurialism to mass-produce and
mass-market products the
entrepreneurship industry has made
possible what we term
the blending entrepreneurship this is
entrepreneurship pursued primarily as a
form of conspicuous consumption and is
fundamentally different from the
innovative
innovation-driven entrepreneurship that
emulates and superficially resembles so
to unpack that a little bit
we've talked about before there's a
sociologist thorstein bevlin
who coined the term conspicuous
consumption this is
uh basically keeping up with the joneses
people buy things
to present an image to their neighbors
to their friends to their loved ones
this is i gotta buy a new sports car
because the neighbor's got a sports car
i have to look like i'm doing well i
have to sort of transmit this message
um there's also what's called the
blennian goods which is
you know a good that becomes more
desirable as it gets more expensive
again part of that sort of
circuit of conspicuous consumption but
the whole argument is that
this is what the consuming and
purchasing of courses on
entrepreneurship
um you know all this whole industry has
become
is that people spend a thousand dollars
on a class they'll spend 5 000 it must
be extra good on a class
um and they really want to signal to the
world in a sort of conspicuous
consumption kind of way that they are an
entrepreneur i'm sure you've seen this
in your social media feeds
you know whether it's a person with an
mlm uh and they've like started their
own business quote unquote whether it's
like
some dude who's taking pictures of some
ferrari or private jet he's rented
i love those guys yeah those guys are
the greatest um
uh so i think it's really interesting i
think it's something we've all
encountered a lot i also find it
interesting because this is uh this
isn't
this is a business professor basically
saying that
this is a problem for like the market
right in that uh
this is what he says but my take is
basically capitalism's destroying
capitalism like the conspicuous
consumption
of entrepreneurship and sort of
capitalist ethics is destroying the
quality
of like because the market needs good
businesses a diverse range of businesses
new ideas
disruption etc etc etc but when it's
basically all these wannabes that's not
great for things
um yeah yeah do you so how much does
that relate to
conspicuous consumption thing to like
because what this always makes me think
of this
is that innovation is like a lie and
what i mean by that is
all of the startups and entrepreneurs
also anyone who says they're an
entrepreneur is sus
like anyone can just say that people
just say they're an entrepreneur why
because you started an llc like you shut
up
but um this whole notion of innovation
seems to be built on top of this
economic ideology of infinite growth
that there's this possibility
of infinite growth that's what all these
um you know venture capitalists who
people think are really smart who aren't
smart they just invest in a hundred
different things and one of them works
out and in any other field if you
if your odds were 1 in 100 you would be
bad at the thing um
but are built upon this idea of infinite
growth rather than someone like starting
a business that's simply
sustainable and can provide like a
lifestyle for their employees or
something like that
um and it seems to me like the mindset
of like millennial and gen z people who
are paying for scam courses online to
start businesses
are just caught up in this really faulty
ideology
of purely infinite growth and that
that's like
accelerating all of the worst aspects of
contemporary capitalism
but does that i mean does that seem to
be a part of this too or am i just
getting conspiratorial
i don't think you're conspiratorial i
don't think it's exactly i i think to be
honest it's a spectrum you have the sort
of
entrepreneur or entrepreneur whatever
class they are
who uh you know wants to make
like a good six figure income whatever
and then there's the people who are like
i'm gonna make the next uber
um now granted you know one of the the
sort of analogies that comes out is like
this is like professional sports you
have
millions of people who want to do this
thing and like maybe 100
who succeed right um and so
i think it's not quite all infinite
growth i mean
again i would describe it even as a
spectrum like there are people who might
take
um you know business courses who are
trying to start a business and maybe
they're sort of signaling
their sort of entrepreneurship in
different levels on social media
and i'm sure there are cases where it's
murky of like
oh are you just trying to start a
restaurant in your hometown and doing
that but maybe
you're a little like too forward with
like the look at this cool car i have
and if only we had an mba on this
podcast an
expert in the field of business who
could explain all this to us
i think it's an indication of maybe
people wanting to
be their own boss and not want to work
like one thing that i've heard a lot
recently is um and i think this is this
has to do with
a part of it is like the rise of social
media and influencers like you can have
a career as an influencer
so i think people see like younger
generations see
um entrepreneurship is not something
that's unattainable like now
they can do it and with the internet and
being able to connect with anybody
around the world you can sell things
people websites have made it easier to
um
be an entrepreneur like etsy and ebay
and things like that you can sell things
directly to consumers so
i think it i think it could just be like
this
this shift whereas older generations
thought that you had to get a
a job you worked at the same company for
20 years or whatever and then you
retired
um and now people want to be their own
boss they don't want to work for other
people they want to set their own hours
they want more flexibility
so that's what i think when i hear of
this
um this change one thing you said
earlier about
wanting to keep up with the joneses and
wanting to like buy certain things to
project an image um and this is a little
this is totally off topic but
wanting to project an image um
i i feel i live in an i live in an
affluent area
and i feel pressured to
uh dress up when i go out and to to look
um a certain way not because i want
people to think that i'm rich
but so that people don't think that i'm
poor and then treat me like [ __ ]
because i'm a person of color living in
a predominantly
caucasian area so they'll naturally
assume that i have
no money and they'll treat me um very
badly
so i feel like i have to to do those
things i mean i'm not like renting a
private jet
but i definitely can't go out in yoga
pants
like the white girl next door right
unless they're 500 yoga pants then it
might be unless they're 500
yoga plants that say like gucci gotta
get those gucci yoga pants on the ass
um yeah oh go ahead alec well i was
gonna say the beer embossing i think it
like it it makes sense but one of the
problems that this sort of interview
outlines
is that i mean i 100 get that and i
think that's
sort of part of the the gig economy at
large and you know
there that goes over to like freelance
graphic designers and you know all this
other stuff
but i think it's and to be honest it's
similar to the mlm
problem people want to be their own boss
and they want like financial
they want to make a good living you know
some maybe they're sort of dreaming a
little too high of like i'm going to
make millions of dollars doing this but
yeah at the end of the day i think
people
want to pay their bills they want to
save money they want to go on cocaine
vendors
and so what what's what sort of is
brought up in this interview
is that people who are an entrepreneur
as a career like we only talk about and
we only have interviews with
the survivors of that right the people
who succeeded the people who started
uber
but when you do this as a career you're
more likely
to make less money if even if you work
for entrepreneurs like in startups your
sort of average career earnings
according this academic are lower
and you know on the the sort of uh
there's always examples to be like well
i worked for the startup and i got you
know a 400 000
stock grant it worked out for me that's
true but you know it's it's the nba
athlete problem
right yeah i think serbia made a really
important distinction before
between like the person who whether
they're an influencer or starts an
etsy business or something on their own
versus
the sort of like magical thinking of a
lot of entrepreneurship
because i do think someone who like
makes cool [ __ ] on etsy
um has a tangible product and is able to
actually make money off that without the
need of speculative investment
that's great and honestly like i might
i've probably trashed influencing before
on this podcast i apologize
but most influencers are better at
business than most
entrepreneurial startups because the
startups don't make money they have
negative income
whereas the influencers at least are
bringing in positive revenue
so i think there's like this distinction
between those who want to branch out on
their own
by you know having a product or a
service that is a
tangible thing they create and are able
to bring in positive income for
and people who you know sell ideas who
don't have tangible products and it's
all built on speculative investment
and you know out of these people too i
just have to say like my least favorite
type of person in this world
is a tangent but i'll say it are like
the tim ferrisses and gary v's of the
world
who have never really done anything but
write books about how you can do the
things they've never done and make a ton
of money off that
and who've like come into inherited
wealth made one good investment and now
they make millions
on like speaking tours and online
courses and all that [ __ ] it's just the
biggest scam artist [ __ ]
so start an etsy store but either way
that was important distinction
serving made before i i will say uh if
anyone's been
involved in any sort of like part of
this whether
taking you know online courses for a
hundred dollars or a thousand dollars
um i mean i get it i i kind of want to
hear from you email us at culturebingeos
wisecrack.co
um maybe maybe you've been the coach i
don't know i i just want to hear it all
because i think the whole space is very
fascinating and
again it is the spectrum of like the
most outright scams to like oh this is
good business advice but most of the
people who get this advice still aren't
going to succeed and
maybe that's okay you know i have a good
scam entrepreneurial company story but i
think i might have signed an nda that
means i'm sure i shouldn't talk about it
yeah i know about that
i'll look at it i'll all i'll say is
that many many
many companies are are not are they're
full of [ __ ] um but yeah i would love to
hear people's stories with that i would
love to hear
uh any examples of people getting caught
up in this stuff any final thoughts on
this before we move on to what i am
finding the most fascinating
and and thought provoking topic of the
day
okay so often oh alex are you guys on
your side i was gonna say if you start a
business obviously email serbia and give
her a one percent ownership stake just
for no work
caught us in she has an mba i mean yeah
but also caught up
your idea is dumb or not yes everyone
send business ideas
to you know culture binge wisecrack.com
and serbia will respond with either yes
or no
nothing else we'll just tell you if
business idea is good or bad because she
has things to do
like get gucci sweatpants so you can
walk around the neighborhood comfortably
now most weeks on this podcast you know
topics come up and we you know
we share links to things and then for
the most part we like look at them
because we want to be informed going
into this
this is the rare case where i saw
serbia's topic and just thought to
myself
i want to know nothing because i want to
i want to experience this live i want
somebody to explain what happened
and i just want to experience it like an
enthusiastic child who who knows nothing
so
all i know serbia is we're going to
learn about french cave people
it's not that exciting i should have uh
written a little bit more in telegram i
saw the excitement and i was like oh
they're going to be disappointed
no so over the weekend 15 volunteers
emerged
from a dark cave in southwestern france
for 40 days the group lived and explored
the cave as part of the
deep time project scientists at the
human
adaption institute led a 1.2 million
euro which is one and a half million
dollars
project and they say that the experiment
will help them better understand how
people
adapt to drastic changes in living
conditions and
environments so inside the cave there
was no sunlight the temperature was 10
degrees celsius which is 50 degrees
fahrenheit
and their relative humidity was a
hundred percent
and uh the people the volunteers had no
contact with
with anybody with family friends they
couldn't watch the news they had nothing
um participants naturally lost their
sense of time
uh when the researchers went to go get
them to tell them that their 40 days was
up one volunteer thought that they had
been there for only 23 days while others
believed that it was closer to
30 days and
the volunteers followed their biological
clocks to know when to
wake up go to sleep and eat and they
counted days and sleep cycles rather
than hours because they didn't have
cell phones or watches and
when they emerged from the cave i
thought this was really
interesting two-thirds stated that they
wish they could have stayed in the cave
longer
and they wanted to finish group projects
and there's no information about what
these group projects
were but they oh 100
i was like french people in the cave i
was like 100 cave orgies
and
one one participant said that
it was like pressing pause on her life
and she felt like there was there wasn't
a rush to do anything and she also said
she wanted to be in the cave longer
and this is interesting to me because
first of all it feels like a lot of
money just
to spend on having 15 people in the cave
but also
i'm i'm unsure whether it's because it
already feels like we've all been
confined and living in the cave for a
past year but
um or it's like spending 40 days with
strangers in a confined space um
i just couldn't do it in any case i've
been thinking about
their desire to remain in the cave and
the feeling of pressing pause on your
life and not having to worry about
what's going to happen in the next
hour or two it it feels like this
experiment tells a story of people not
wanting to
um people of people not being able to
live in the moment
or feel free from obligations and
even when you're on vacation it's not
like you can stop making decisions most
of the time you still
have to deal with challenges or rush to
get to the airport or
figure out food or whatever and if you
have children and families you have to
consider
their well-being as well so
in the cave you don't have to worry
about anything the food was
given to you you could sleep you could
work on your group projects you could
ride your little bike to
get electricity um you could just exist
so it's not unsurprising to me after i
thought about it that people would want
to
to stay in the cave um because who would
want to
go back to real life and like deal with
the pandemic and
go to work and deal with everything else
so
i wouldn't want to live in a cave with
other strangers but i can see the appeal
and wanting to disconnect completely
from the world
and wanting to focus on small tasks that
could make me
feel productive i'm very interested in
what these group projects were
and if any one listening is a cave
dweller
who participated in this one of the 15
people yeah
the audience reach out desperate to
speak to you
i think they were starting business they
were starting businesses to teach people
business classes was the group project
oh
boy oh boy okay this is like both really
cool and really sad
because to me it's just like modern life
is so [ __ ]
that they put these people in a [ __ ]
damp cave
with no time or anything and they were
like please don't make us come out
and these are french people have 37 hour
work weeks and mandatory one-hour lunch
breaks
and [ __ ] eight years off if they get
pregnant um not really eight years off
it's like one
but like french life isn't even that bad
all things considered great great wine
culture too
and they wanted to stay in the cave that
just makes me sad
it yeah it reminds me of uh there's
like in psychoanalysis the idea of the
death drive which is like we all want to
return to the warm non-existent embrace
of our mother's womb
in that like life is painful it hurts
and don't we just want to not exist and
it feels like
instead of a womb it's a cave and
instead of death it's group projects i
don't know
yeah i was i don't know if they said
anything in the article about this
survey but like one thought too is
without
the sun god i just feel like did no one
have seasonal affective disorder in
there i just feel like i would get so
low energy i wonder if they gave them
vitamin supplements also i don't know
how long it takes to kick in
vitamin ritalin or vitamin cocaine or
something no isn't it
seasonal it's a vitamin it's vitamin d
vitamin d yeah and you can do light box
therapy
maybe they got light boxes on their
bikes um
there there's not a lot of information
about this no information about light
boxes
vitamins hopefully they make a
documentary so we can watch it and see
what it was like
yeah i would be interested in watching
it i
want to know how shitty their lives were
that they would prefer a group project
like i hate group projects i bet their
lives were good though even if we look
into it like
some of these people had good jobs they
had families imagine if you were the
spouse of one of these people
and they're like please don't make me
leave the cave and you're like dad
dad i want you to come home
i just i'm i'm also very curious how no
one got in a fight
or like ha like 40 days with other
humans
like you didn't get in an argument there
was no decision
someone would kill someone else because
because you know some would say we might
go back
to like a state of nature in there and
yeah yeah
because i was thinking
yeah i would have i would have tried to
find another cave
like i would have dragged my little cot
into another whole
area and just stayed there like i wonder
how much space they had
yeah did they have like individual tents
or pods or they're all in this
one room there were three different
areas in the cave
one was for uh sleeping the other
was for eating and then the third was
like
group project area i believe originally
yeah so you're sleeping you're eating
every [ __ ] yeah those are the three
french life cycles anyways that's what
those people do they sleep they eat and
they screw
that's not a judgment by the way what a
dream yeah
wow um i wonder so is that the business
idea that we construct some cave
colonies in like utah or something
and sell people on that magical
experience of disconnecting from life
but then we have to monetize their time
there so they pay us to be there
but we like sell data or do research on
them or like secretly live stream them
or something
it's like cave airbnb yeah you could
rent a cave
what if you went in the cave and
something really bad happened uh you
know kind of like a 28 days later type
thing
yeah release of liability not involved
it's like what happened to what's the
actor jared leto lido how do we say leto
or lido
latte letto you know he was on a silent
retreat in the desert when like the cove
outbreak happened so he like came out of
it and his first tweet was like i've
been in a silent retreat i've walked
into a new world
he's a weird guy very weird guy
the type of guy who i definitely think
if you gave him the opportunity to go
live in a french cave he would be like
when's
that yeah i would do it
is joaquin phoenix weird or not weird
remember very weird i thought he was
very weird
of like a character my method no no no
no no
he's a weird guy he's weird right yeah
100 weird guy
is what i thought i mean it touched back
to our first topic when he won his best
actor
award last year at the oscars he gave
like a massive speech about
animal consumption and climate change he
shamed his fellow actors for taking
private jets to palm springs
and then him and rooney mara went to a
really good vegan burger place in los
angeles called monty's good burger
and took pictures of themselves eating
that afterwards that's not weird that's
just kind of funny
oh yeah it's not weird i'm saying he's
an eccentric guy and i think there's
many many many indications
of this and i've seen very few examples
of him just seeming like a normal dude
yeah sean penn is weird too right yeah
the three of them are
he's bad though he's a bad man he's done
all this
good stuff recently but it doesn't just
because you do a bunch of good stuff
related to vaccines or issues in haiti
doesn't mean that like not to get too
dark that you didn't like
uh physically abduct and rape and beat
yeah madonna
yeah i wasn't gonna yeah that's the
stuff so he's he's
also a really bad writer he wrote this
novel that's like called like jimmy
crack corn i swear to god it's called
something like that it's like the corn
cob man goes a walk-in
and um it's so bad but then people take
it seriously because it's like sean penn
wrote a book but it's like dog you're a
shitty writer someone should go look up
the sean penn novel uh he's bad
so i think i think we would love to have
you on the show sean penn
yeah so if you're gonna go into a cave
i'd say pen hard no
phoenix yeah lido maybe yeah
that would be my power ranking on those
three hollywood um
men and who would want us to go to a
cave with
yeah because i'm sure that's what
everyone was thinking who would they go
into a cave with that of those people
yeah wow um well i i think serbia you
sold
you undersold this topic at the top i'm
just as fascinated as i thought i would
be
i'm very interested in all this i'm
going to be thinking about the french
cave
most of the day or the cops oh that's
good i
i really want to speak to one of these
participants or their family
um so either why doesn't your partner
love you
why did they yeah okay also maybe we're
just misreading this because you know
the french call their wine cellars caves
so if someone says they have like a wine
cave it's like
yeah so if you ever like in like france
you see like uh
you know a sort of like the cave devon
or whatever it is
so maybe there was a bunch of french
people that were in a wine cellar for 40
days and they were like we don't want to
come out like no wonder they lost track
of time
um so if you have been to a
a cave experiment recently or if you are
a entrepreneur or if you have thoughts
on beef
we want to hear about it so you can do
two things to let us know
um you can call us at 213-534-8807 that
is 213-534-8807 or you can email us at
culturebinge
wisecrack.co no m
culture binge at wisecrack dot co um and
obviously you can you can find one of us
as well so
today serbia gave context clues you want
to find an upperclass area of the
country where people wear expensive
sweatpants
and you might find her i'm alec i don't
know if he gave any context clues
on to where he lives today um and i
think i gave one context clue
that involved a vegan uh burger
establishment so happy hunting
um but in the meantime while we wait for
people to call and email
us who do did we get any emails
from this past week alec yeah no voi uh
no voicemails
but we've got a couple good emails that
i'm gonna read
and i will pull those up because i did
not lose the document again
he didn't lose it he's on top of things
everyone
he lost it um well and you know just to
say in general
i hope everyone knows this we love
getting your emails recently we've
gotten some great fan
art that we've really loved um we can't
read
art right maybe if we got really high on
mescaline we could like interpret the
art
um sweet but we love that
we love the art we love hearing from
everyone in general and hope everyone
knows if your email or voicemail doesn't
get
played or read on the show it doesn't
mean we didn't read it love it etc
this means we get stuff we only have so
much time to do this but we really
appreciate it so keep them coming alec
have you found your notes yeah yeah yeah
all right the first email is from joe
uh wisecrack wisecast crew i have an
android i think this means i can't have
itunes for podcast don't know
uh joe joe's leaving a review as a email
joe is not aware that there's other
podcast platforms where joe could review
us but but it's a good review i want to
read it
five stars if the wisecast crew were all
jedi who would they be
serbie would undeniably be jocasta new
the chief librarian in the jedi archives
leave her alone
let her vibe out with her books but like
if shit's gonna go down she still
carries a lightsaber
that sounds pretty cool i'm interested
in this character wherever they came
from
nice alec is ki adi mundi
big ass binary brain that sounds yeah
bad
uh with outstanding thinking can hold
his own on the jedi council can throw
down with the separatists
and is most likely to be concerned with
the droid attack on the wookiees michael
burns
star wars expert should i be offended by
any of this or very uh
oh this is like real deep i'm pretty
sure these are all coming from like deep
clone wars stuff
but i think no one should be offended
okay uh michael is
uh keeneland voss witty as all hell
doesn't care about your rules and is
just looking for a good time bro
joy from what little we know of joy yes
is shakti
rarely seen but keeps your operation
running humble boss ass
kind of [ __ ] shock t rules joe thank you
i got a good one
thank you so much really appreciate that
also if you
are like joe and you're looking to
review us um it means a lot to us the
reason that he did that is because we
always encourage you if you're going to
review us give us some sort of
categorization
say who we would be if we were star wars
characters if we were blends of coffee
if we were um fine automobiles anything
like that we love it and of course you
can go
on stitcher you can go on itunes make us
a yelp page i don't know
find a place to review us yeah only if
it's good though
also joe said uh if i ever somehow
become super rich then
create a new patreon to your because
i've always dreamt of funding the [ __ ]
out of you guys we love it joe
anyway next time i'm super rich
i've wanted us to i want us to start the
inherited wealth tier of patreon i've
said it before i'll say it again where
we invite people who've inherited
massive amounts of wealth from dead
relatives
they pay a bunch we'll make you whatever
the [ __ ] you want sorry keep going with
the emails
uh i also just want to shout out uh this
is long overdue but israel bravo uh what
up fellow culture heads
serbia mukbang uh thank you for the
discussion
uh but next email is from max hi culture
binge crew love listening your most
recent podcast on the summer of chaos i
wanted to write in regards to michael's
point of view about talking to strangers
and having those short moments
i am both a healthcare and restaurant
worker so i may be more willing to talk
to strangers during this strange time
but i've seen
seemed to have more of these moments
whether it's overhearing someone talking
about a popular show
funny moments while waiting in line etc
i think people are craving any sort of
human connection outside of their small
circle
so even if you're less socially driven
get out there and try to have those
little moments it's brightened my days
immensely thanks again max
thank you max nice email max
appreciate that and i want to be more
like max and get out there and start
having these fun
moments of interaction and communal joy
that's great to hear and eavesdropping
on people is what i'm
excited to do at outdoor cafes anyway uh
email
on people email from craig hi
wisecrackies
uh love the show glad everyone's doing
well down the usfa
looks like you finally have some well
deserved optimism unfortunately up in
canada it feels like the pandemic has
just started we have the worst coveted
numbers at any point in our deep into
our third or fourth lockdowns with
police checkpoints at bridges
and apm curfews in some places smiley
emoji
hearing the topics of the show about
summer chaos and returning to office i
had to stop listening it seems so far
away
from that up here it was just painful to
listen to lol
there's a lot of very negative things
here craig punctuated by
fun light-hearted emojis and i'm just
saying it's okay to be sad
anyway that sucks i didn't i didn't
realize that i feel bad now that we're
just out here
like yeah bragging about stuff
and sucks yeah uh as someone likely six
months away from being able to do
anything social obviously this is just
up to your comfort levels but go do
something social when you
first can even if it's just hugging a
parent or friend anyway love what you do
keep on
and go keep keep on keeping on and go
and take your shirt off and hug a
stranger when it's reasonably safe to do
so
when anthony fauci says we can
wait did he say take your shirt off in
august he said take a shower i'm saying
that's awesome she says i can take my
shirt off and hug strangers i will
we'll do so uh yeah i'm sorry you know
we got a lot of international listers
from brazil
from canada um the united states has
obviously
been the uh well one of the worst
epicenters of
uh the the pandemic and so it feels like
oh well it's getting
better here obviously it's getting
better everywhere but it's not
obvious we just talked about india is
having a real bad spike
uh canada has some vaccine issues
uh and so sorry we'll try to not
throw throat in everyone's face that
yeah um
you know being vaccinated is cool which
is well and as
as members of the non-terror group
called the flag smashers we wish that
there weren't these borders
and that everyone could get access to
vaccinations equitably
and fairly if it wasn't for that damn
falcon and his friends we could do it
that's it those are the oh that's it
thank you great you thank you so much
for ever running in
uh thank you for listening craig sorry
that we
ruined your day and maybe your life to
be honest i don't know no i hope we
didn't ruin your life very sorry um
and greg whenever whenever we can we'll
come to canada
and and buy you a molson or whatever it
is you drink because technically we are
we're kind of employees of a canadian
company
um so i think we're allowed to just go
whenever we want and
uh we get things for free that said
please write an email us four eight
everyone um
that's two one three five three three
three
three
three
three
three
three three
three
three
three
three
three three
three
three
three
three
three three
three
three
three
three
three three
three
three
three
three
three three
three
three
three
three
three three
three
three
three
three
three three
three
three
three
three
three three
three
three
three
three
three three
three
three
three
three
three three
three
three
three
three
three three
three
three
three
three
three three three three three four eight eight
zero seven culture wisecrack deco as
always
um if you like the podcast subscribe
rate
review however you can do it there's
many ways you're all smart
um and just make make the review fun we
want you we know that you're all
creative
weird funny bizarre insightful and we
want to see that in reviews we'll
definitely read them on here when we get
them
and we'll be back in a couple weeks uh
and just you know pay attention we'll
try to tweet it out or something like
that if we're gonna broadcast on a
different day than our regular wednesday
because we want you to know we want you
to be here so you can be in the chat um
unless you're you're
you're you're not based and we don't
want you in the chat um but in the
meantime
any other any other comments from y'all
for this one are we ready to sign off
ready sign off thanks so much for the
fan art
keep it coming thank you for the art
keep it coming and we will see you all
together in a cave soon it's gonna get
weird um this has been culture binge
goodbye
[Music]
you